[Music]
all right so I've got about a month a
little less than a month to move
everything everything from this studio
space down to the new one and that's
what I've committed to working on now
for I guess the foreseeable future the I
was told by the building that they've
already committed this space to be moved
into by a new tenant so they're gonna
move into this studio on May 1st so
right now it's April 6th as I record
this now I don't even know if that
tenant given the circumstances actually
plans to move in on May 1st but that's
that's the paperwork that they've signed
so now the clock is ticking on me to
actually move to our new space that's
the goalpost now that I've got a hit
originally I was playing on having maybe
a few more weeks than that as we like
furnish that space and get you know
sound dampening material and actually
set that up and get the the window
blinds and all that stuff in there so
that we could just have a smooth
transition from shooting here to
shooting there but now we're just gonna
have to just expedite all that I guess
luckily though this new space is in the
same building so our move is a little
bit less difficult it's not like we're
moving things into trucks driving and
then unloading them or more moving them
into an elevator but yeah now given my
expedited timeline this may be this may
very well be the last video shot
primarily in this studio space there may
be some stuff still occasionally shot up
here but honestly this may be the last
of it it's very possible
so I figured I would give you guys a
little bit of a behind-the-scenes look
if that Quarantine content helps keep
you entertained of how exactly I am
moving everything from here to down
there but here I might as well show you
my progress so far 24
this might not mean anything to you if
you didn't remember what this looked
like but there you go
[Music]
24/7 so this is this is what Studio a
looks like right now it's obviously got
stuff and it's still but it looks miles
different miles more empty than it did
like the two weeks ago that I started
this whole moving stuff downstairs
process so you know you might recognize
some of the stuff behind me I never
really did like a traditional tour of
the the full space I did a VR tour
actually once and I'll link that below
but also links temp scheffers tour that
he did here maybe a year or so ago which
is where this footage is from and this
is about as final as this studio space
looked so the number one thing you may
notice now is a lot of the floor is gone
so you may or may not have ever known
this depending on what videos you've
watched but the entire gray floor in
this space is made up of interlocking 1
foot by 1 foot carpeted floor tiles
great for sound dampening great for
lighting great for video definitely a
pain in the ass to lay down thousands of
them to fill up a studio space as big as
this one but yeah that's what I've been
doing pulling these up one by one row by
row bring them downstairs and
reassembling them one by one row by row
so that they sort of replace the photos
in here down in that part of that new
space I'll show you that in a minute but
yeah then there's just a lot of other
stuff to move lights C stands desks
couches rugs wardrobes just a ton of
furniture there's just a lot of stuff to
to move down there now knowing that you
might be wondering marques why don't you
just hire some movers to help you just
just lift up all the stuff move it down
there you'll be super easy why don't you
just do that good question my answer is
like I know there are professional
movers that are very very good at what
they do but for some reason for whatever
reason I don't really fully trust
professional movers no matter who they
are to correctly move a lot of this tech
stuff the TVs
death would you trust professional
movers if you had a closet of of red
cameras and video gear would you just
let them move it for you I don't know I
feel like if I'm gonna do a lot of it
myself I might as well see how much of
it I can do myself plus there's a whole
social distancing stuff obviously you
don't want to have a whole bunch of
people in the same space at once this
studio has been empty I've been coming
in here solo as you know and you know
there's some occasional construction
still going on in the building because
construction is essential but yeah I
feel like I can just see how much I can
get done yeah so I've been moving all
this stuff bit by bit
very carefully let me show you how so
I've had to get kind of creative with
this stuff I've measured every doorway I
need to get through and this next desk
on wheels is actually kind of the
perfect size to fit through every door
or between here and the new studio so
with furniture blanket and this desk
I've basically turned it into a dolly
that's just excessively high off the
ground so I pick a piece of furniture to
move slide the makeshift dolly into
place lock the two locking wheels on
each side of the next desk so it doesn't
move then I slide the blanket towards
the half of the desk that I'm about to
put the furniture on since the furniture
will slide it back onto the desk then I
pick up one half of the furniture and
put it on that covered half of the desk
couple check make sure everything's
still positioned well and not sliding
then the precarious bit pick up the
other side of that piece of furniture
and slide it onto the desk using the
blanket to sort of guide it into place
and make sure it's not overhanging too
much over one side of the other then
once it's all set I can unlock both
wheels on the impressively strong next
desk and maybe wrap up the corners or
the edges of the furniture if any of
them are in danger of hitting a wall or
a doorway then start to roll that thing
out of there now I have four main points
of extreme caution the doorway to the
studio is the first one just have to
make sure I slide it through without
hitting the door or the column in the
hallway outside of the door then the
next one is the elevator but luckily we
have these massive ten
foot freight sighs elevators in the
building so pretty much everything fits
in them I just got to make sure the
wheels of the next desk don't get caught
while rolling into the elevator then
once I get downstairs and out of the
elevator I got to get through another
temporary door thanks to the
construction but this one's a little
bigger than the studio so if I fit
through the studio door I can definitely
fit through this temp door and I have a
tape measure I've done that measuring
trust me ten I can walk it down the
hallway to the studio the long empty
somewhat ominous hallway and then I get
it to the studio and then that is the
one final door that I have to get it
into to get whatever piece of furniture
I've been moving fully through those
pain points and I'm in so that's what
we've been doing for that's what I've
been doing for all this all this all
this all this yeah
doesn't start an Apple watch workout but
you know how sometimes it asks you hey
do you want to start a workout I feel
like I should start like a strength
workout or something I'd say the most
precarious piece of furniture to move so
far has probably been the LG 88 inch TV
that I did that dope tech video on I
think it weighs about a hundred maybe
150 pounds with the stand it's on but
it's a very balanced thing obviously you
don't want it tipping over too much but
basically the same process here get the
desk over here lock the wheels slide the
blanket into place reconsider the whole
decision move the table around a bit put
some styrofoam back there as a safety
mechanism like an anchor reconsider
everything again they just commit you
lift up the TV from one side on the side
of the stand place it on the locked desk
and then just really try to line up
everything so won't fall so sliding the
rest of it on is as easy as possible
then carefully tiptoe around to the
other side so you don't bump anything
and then get the other half of the TV up
in the air and slide it onto the desk
this time I forgot to account for how
much the blanket would slide but hey at
least I protected half of my makeshift
dolly then I'm off to the hallways
trusting doorways elevators and this
incredibly strong metal desk on wheels
to not collapse and do its job which it
did so that's where that leaves us so
far let me add clearly
not a lot of soundproofing material in
here but let me know if you'd be down to
see more videos or more more of this the
the moving into the space the the kitted
out how I add tech to the space I could
see it being future videos in between
other tech stuff if you're down leave a
thumbs up if you're interested in that
but uh this is also probably a good time
to mention I don't recommend any of the
furniture moving that I've shown in this
video like that there should be a little
disclaimer like I'm not responsible for
if you try to move furniture this way
don't try this at home don't try this
anywhere just a little bit of a vlog for
you oh yeah clearly there's a lot
happening feel free to subscribe if you
haven't already to see more updates as
they happen and that's pretty much been
it for this one thanks for watching hope
you're staying safe staying responsible
get you guys the next one peace